the half-pound water hiccup as a small
African bird has formed a mutual defense
pact with a slightly larger animal the
ferocious half-ton Nile crocodile you
can imagine how the croc might protect
the dicker but what can a bird do for
the croc this hungry monitor lizard
hunting for crocodile eggs is about to
find out the monitor lizard knows it's
near what at once but on water nickim
couple is having none of it these tiny
bodies seem to hold more than their
share of massed academies the monitor
lizard doesn't give up and neither do
the dick ups that are of course
protecting their own nest as well
finally the mother croc has roused by
this ruckus and scares off the lizard
with her growl
[Music]
alas mama croc can't guard her eggs all
day
the hundred-degree Heat drives her into
the water and the water de cups are left
guarding both nests which means the
opportunistic monitor lizard is back
sniffing out those Crocs with it's time
the monitor lizard knows when to strike
it rains the nest eats what it can the
croc realizes what's going on in her own
backyard but a poignant seed consumes a
mother croc carries eggs for 12 to 14
weeks and then guards them for another
three months before they hatched she'll
have to wait a year and have another
brood to make up for this croc
catastrophe and when that happens
successful or not
the water dick up will once again be her
first line of defense